pompidou est mort lui dr agonise lra
s'entre déchirent ce spectacle pour nous
est tout à fait satisfaisant la
différence fondamentale qui sépare
chavent destin de giscard delmas ce
n'est pas la feuille d'impôts ce n'est
pas l'accordéon ce n'est pas le tennis
c'est tout simplement qu'ils veulent
être tous les deux présidents de la
république pour mener à peu près la même
politique
quant à roy y est vous l'avez reconnu
c'est le maréchal pétain qui parle
alors on nous dit mais puisque vous êtes
d'accord pour balayer toute cette clique
pourquoi ne pas voter pour françois
mitterrand dès le premier tour
c'est la seule solution réaliste et bien
nous disons non n'avons aucune confiance
dans françois mitterrand nous croyons qu
aujourd'hui c'est tout le problème de la
société capitaliste qui est posée c'est
toute la logique d'un système qui est en
cause d'un système tout ce qui est
produits lettres uniquement en fonction
du profit et non pas pour satisfaire les
besoins des gens là système par exemple
où les frais de publicité en france
représente le double du budget de la
santé où l'armée coûte plus cher que
l'école où des milliards ont été
gaspillés pour toute une série de
scandales comme celui de la ville être
d'un système où malgré les progrès
scientifiques les conditions de travail
et de vie sont de plus en plus pénible
une moyenne de 45 heures de travail par
semaine
c'est la plus grande d'europe un
accident de travail mortel
toutes les heures sept cent mille
chômeurs des millions de femmes qui
travaillent de 70 à 80 heures par
semaine
si l'on compte et il faut le faire les
tâches domestiques 800 1000 avortements
clandestins chaque année du fait d'une
ou un bep civ 2 millions de travailleurs
immigrés il est vrai qu'ils ne votent
pas mais deux millions de travailleurs
immigrés surexploités lié directement au
contrôle de la police et enfin trois
cent mille jeunes soldats qui perdent un
an de leur existe
le crâne rasé la cervelle laver et puis
pour protéger tout cet ordre qui est
leur ordre cent mille policiers
des centaines de barbouze la cft dans
les usines des milliers d'écoutés
téléphoniques et leurs dernières
découvertes l'ordinateur safari plus une
armée qui prépare la guerre civile c'est
cela la société de profits
c'est cela la société capitaliste et sa
face brive ou bien on est contraint d'en
subir totalement la logique alors que
dit aujourd'hui françois mitterrand
aujourd'hui pas hier quand il était
ministre avec chaban delmas du
gouvernement la défense celui 7
l'antenne il déclarait récemment comment
pourrions nous être contre le profit
dans une économie de marché où la france
se trouve par sa nature même par son
appartement son marché commun et par
laird influence américaine
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en bref deux
choses très simples premièrement je suis
avec les américains et je compte bien y
rester
deuxièmement pas question pour moi
d'attaquer le profit et que pense le
parti communiste de cette politique
il ne dit rien il se tait honteusement
alors réfléchissons un peu
si demain mitterrand est élu ce qui est
possible chabrol giscard s'en vont tant
mieux et c'est pour cela qu'au deuxième
tour nous appellerons à voter pour
mitterrand
mais le capitalisme il reste alors
certains disent ira quand même 9
nationalisation en cinq ans mais cette
nationalisation ne remettent pas en
cause la logique du système capitaliste
allez demander aux travailleurs de
renault si l'exploitation a cessé à
billancourt en fait mitterrand ne veux
pas effrayer les patrons n'ont même plus
loin il annonce qu'il est prêt à
indemniser les sociétés nationalisées
cela veut dire concrètement qu'il pourra
donner de l'argent à heat était le trust
qui a organisé le coup d'état au chili
si mitterrand pas les patrons eux
restent et par conséquent nos
revendications demeurent par exemple les
400 francs minimum que demandait il ya
peu de temps mais c'était avant les
élections la cgt la scène
t les 200 francs d'augmentation pour
tous pour lesquels se sont battus des
dizaines de milliers de travailleurs
comme ceux de la thomson ou ceux des
chantiers de saint nazaire l'échelle
mobile des salaires façon les indices de
l'insee
mais sur les indices des organisations
syndicales la retraite à 55 ans la
semaine de 35 heures sans diminution de
salaire
l'égalité des droits pour les
travailleurs français immigrés pour les
hommes et les femmes la contraception et
l'avortement libre et gratuit pour tout
y compris pour les mineurs parce que si
cette revendication immédiate ne sont
même pas satisfaites par un gouvernement
de gauche
comment peut-on prétendre changer la vie
même un tout petit peu nous avertissons
françois mitterrand nous ne voulons pas
d'un gouvernement guy mollet willy
brandt wilson nous nous voulons
réellement changer la vie mais pour cela
il ne peut pas y avoir de trêve avec le
patronat nous savons d'ailleurs que la
bourgeoisie se prépare à une telle
expérience et qu'elle peut essayer de
faire ce qu'elle a déjà fait en espagne
en indonésie en grèce ayez au chili or
mitterrand pas plus que le président
allende ne veut s'attaquer un tant soit
peu à l'appareil d'état il prétend même
respecter la constitution de 1958 qui
est quand même une constitution issu
d'un coup d'état militaire celui d'alger
il prétend laisser intact l'armée et la
police
créer du quai entraîné contre les
travailleurs jamais contre les patrons
les travailleurs doivent dès à présent
prévenir tous les massues tous les
apprentis pinochet de français que même
si mitterrand peut être si complaisant à
leur égard que les dirigeants d'unité
populaire au chili eux ne marcheront pas
ils ont tiré toutes les leçons de
l'expérience chilienne et qu'ils agiront
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
alors on nous dit mais vous êtes des
gauchistes d irréaliste vous voulez tout
tout de suite
nous disons non parfois les travailleurs
sont amenés à faire des compromis et
nous disons aux dirigeants du
la gauche si aujourd'hui vous sacrifier
les luttes des travailleurs pour gagner
quelques voix à droite
si demain vous tendent elles annoncent
d'officiers réactionnaire pour ne pas
effrayer les bourgeois si vous leur
laissez tous les leviers de commande
dans les mains mais alors vous allez
désormais la classe ouvrière et vous
allez laisser tout le loisir à la
bourgeoisie de s'organiser pour préparer
une contre offensive
voilà l'ensemble des problèmes que nous
allons développer pendant cette campagne
et si nous aiderons mithra à passer au
deuxième tour il importe dès maintenant
de préparer en toute lucidité les
prochaines échéances de combat parce
qu'on ne construit pas le socialisme par
surprise
ou alors on sur fond la classe ouvrière
mais pas la bourgeoisie
[Musique]